KAMALA HARRIS IS DOING.
THE FOX TEAM COVERAGE TONIGHT,
CASEY STEGALL ON THE BORDER IN
SOUTH TEXAS.
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
KRISTIN FISHER ON THE LAWN WITH
THE LATEST, GOOD EVENING.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET THE
WHITE HOUSE CLARIFYING THE ROLE
OF THE U.S. BORDER A WEEK AFTER
THAT SHE WOULD BE THE DIPLOMATIC
LEAD ON THIS EFFORT.
A BIG ANNOUNCING QUESTION ABOUT
WHEN VICE PRESIDENT
KAMALA HARRIS WOULD TAKE EIGHT
TRIP TO THE BORDER.
AND THAT BP SAID NOT TAKING THE
LEAD ON THE ADMINISTRATION’S
RESPONSE TO THE CRISIS AT THE
BORDER.
INSTEAD, HER FOCUSES STRICTLY ON
DIPLOMACY WITH MEXICO AND THE
THREE NORTHERN TRANQUIL
COUNTRIES TO ADDRESS ROOT CAUSES
OF MIGRATION AND TO OVERSEE THE
FLOW OF U.S. AID TO THOSE
COUNTRIES.
SPEAK WITH THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES WILL BE
HELPING LEAD THAT EFFORT,
SPECIFICALLY THE ROOT CAUSES,
NOT THE BORDER.
THERE IS SOME CONFUSION OVER
THAT.
>> WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
JEN PSAKI SAID THE WHITE HOUSE
HAS NO IMMEDIATE PLANS TO VISIT
THE BORDER BUT PRESIDENT TRUMP
SAYS HE PLANS TO TAKE A TRIP IN
THE NEXT FEW WEEKS.
AS FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN WHO WAS
ASKED ABOUT HIS PREDECESSOR’S
PLANS ON SUNDAY...
>> WE ARE PUTTING IN PLACE A
PLAN THAT I’M STILL VERY
CONFIDENT ABOUT, AND I DON’T
CARE WHAT THE OTHER GUY DOES.
>> U.S. CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PROTECTION IS EXPECTING A
SURGEON UNACCOMPANIED MIGRANT
CHILDREN.
AND THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY WAS PRESSED ABOUT THAT
PREDICTION DURING THE BRIEFING
TODAY BUT SHE AGAIN PUNTED TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY.
>> I DON’T HAVE ANY PREDICTIONS
THAT COME FROM CDP OR THE
HOMELAND SECURITY BUT OUR FOCUS
NOW IS ON ENSURING THAT WE HAVE
ENOUGH SHELTER FACILITIES TO
HOUSE UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN.
>> MORE SHELTERS AND FACILITIES
MEANS A NEED FOR PEOPLE TO CARE
FOR THE MIGRANT CHILDREN HOUSED
INSIDE.
THE NEED TO SO GREAT THAT LAST
WEEK THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
SENT A MEMO TO THE HEAD OF
MULTI-GOVERNMENT AGENCIES ASKING
FOR CIVILIAN FEDERAL EMPLOYEES
TO VOLUNTEER FOR DEPLOYMENT OF
UP TO 120 DAYS.
A SPOKESPERSON FOR THE OFFICE OF
PERSONNEL MANAGEMENT CONFIRMED
ACTIVELY WORKING TO SCREEN
PROCESS, AND DEPLOY THESE
VOLUNTEERS TO BOLSTER STAFF
RESOURCES AT THE BORDER.
REPUBLICAN SENATOR TOM COTTON
WHO VISITED THE BORDER LAST WEEK
SAYS IT IS PAST THE POINT OF A
CRISIS.
>> ASKING FEDERAL EMPLOYEES TO
GO TO THE BORDER ADDRESSES THE
SYMPTOMS NOT THE CAUSE.
BECAUSE JOE BIDEN OPEN OPEN THE
BORDER.
>> STILL NO PLANS FOR
PRESIDENT BIDEN TO VISIT THE
BORDER, BUT HE DID JUST MAKE A
SURPRISE TRIP ALONG WITH THE
FIRST LADY TO THE VIETNAM
VETERANS MEMORIAL MAN NEXT TRIP
IS TO PITTSBURGH ON WEDNESDAY TO